[Musica]
a sei anni ero al meglio e 36
sapevo che sempre si faceva 36 videoclip
che a sette le sarei diventato 149 a 81
64 al 91 81 è a 10 1 in cento e questo
non mi convincerà dal fantasma
equivalente decisi di restare su metro e
81 che la mia statura attuale oggi sono
qui per provare a convincervi della
ragione per cui io sono convinto che
siamo fatti della stessa materia dei
soldi allora per iniziare questo viaggio
percorso insieme di parlare della
biomimetica la dimentica una disciplina
dei processi biologici che sarebbe anche
diciamoci far copiare dalla natura per
migliorare la nostra tecnologia e per
migliorare le nostre attività umane e ad
esempio abbiamo in velcro il look rose
che rinvenuto che si attacca aversi agli
studi sul tema è strano che decise di
capire ad un certo punto com'era
possibile che il seme di questa pianta
la rai tv forse così tenente leggermente
facilmente si attaccasse così
tenacemente facilmente al mero del suo
carico di volta che uscivano per fare
una camminata e poi gli studi sul sulla
famiglia del noto gli studi sul lato via
del lodo che ci diede la possibilità di
inventare le materiali impermeabili sul
quale sui quali l'acqua scivola via
anziché esserne assorbita ma abbiamo
anche degli studi sul finiti delle
termiti
e in questo caso innovativi concetti
design tecnologia vpro proprio dagli
studi di questi militari di che in
qualche anno la proprietà di essere al e
una medicazione è una temperatura
costante al loro interno e poi nei
preferiti gli studi sulle sugli animali
sociali quindi sulle abito sulle
formiche che sei in grado di comunicare
tramite la danza la danza particolare
che fanno all'interno del nilo la
posizione la quantità e la qualità del
cibo che diano frera ritroveranno alle
citate all'uscita da libera per alterare
ovviamente siamo tutti convinti che la
nostra bella meravigliosa è fonte di
grande ispirazione eppure abbiamo
qualità questo sentimento di distacco
dalla natura e di distanza dalla natura
che ci fa in questo modo inquinare
disboscare sfruttarne le risorse ad un
punto tale per cui non siamo più a
dotare in cui più in equilibrio con se
stesso ed il motivo io ne parlo denuncia
un po questa distanza del fatto che in
qualche modo ne siamo distanti perché la
cartesio in poi abbiamo deciso che la
res cogitans dovesse in qualche modo
regolare e gestire i processi perché
altrimenti la essex pensa che è propria
di un altro inconsapevole poteva creare
dei problemi
e questa è un florido lavora sempre oggi
detroit delmati invito che per cui
questa energia ceca e
e nazionale l'inconsapevole ok ma questo
è ancora più evidente in alcuni
scienziati moderni che dicono che la
dalla scienza serve in realtà per
controllare predire i processi
dell'universo in qualche modo
controllargli controllare il diverso
questo è l'obiettivo è qui vorrei farmi
inciso particolare rispetto alla mia
esperienza personale nel 2010 parti per
la francia perché in questo punto i miei
compagni amici ricercatori precari
perdemmo la lotta politica che cercava
di affermare una cosa volta del fatto
che disfunzione universitarie bari e
scientifica fossero cose molto
importanti per un paese come l'italia
e allora all'estero la prima cosa che mi
facciano fare con dei corsi di francese
organizza di treviso il catori stranieri
è uno degli esercizi che ci propone di
insegnare quello di proporre le
differenze che avevamo notato nella vivo
in francia rischi fa nostri paesi di
origine ovviamente per me subito subito
un'occasione ghiotta per dire loro che è
la prima sarà valutata che sulla maglia
della loro nazionale di calcio ci stanno
e sono esterni ma quando dell'inter
essere stato 4 però ci fu presa più
seriamente il catania di pubblico con
questo ragazzo cileno che era quello che
è la prima cosa che ho notato è fatto
che in in francia gli alberi sono
inquadrati e questo è vero nel senso che
hanno una copertura particolare che sta
in piedi una società in cui abili e
vedete che gli altri sono i deputati in
questo modo avrà sicuramente
la potatura efficace degli alberi che
migliora la qualità della vita ma c'è un
limite che spesso passiamo su questo
controllo eccessivo che dobbiamo
rispettare la natura questa secondo me
delusa in qualche modo una paura che
viviano collettivamente come manita
questa paura è ben raccontata dall
esperimento mentale per le infinite
scimmie in pratica questo esperimento
dentale dice che infinite scimmie
descrivono in maniera casuale e battono
i tasti di un numero ingente infinito di
macchine da scrivere per un tempo
infinito arriveranno in qualche modo
nella casualità arrivano a questo punto
a scrivere tutte le opere di shakespeare
è la nostra paura è lance nel post
scrittura del senso che quando questo
barlume di lucidità ed illuminazione
sarà albanito le scimmie anche un erano
nella loro casa unitaria quello che la
nostra paura è quella che l'intelligenza
umana in qualche modo possa dire che
quindi l'unico modo per farla continuare
a sopravvivere se quella di controllare
eccessivamente tutto ma una domanda che
mi pongo personalmente è siamo
intelligenti sono norme igieniche pure
un granello di polline e sviluppa i
filamenti per volare contento e noi
questo non ci fa capire che cosa in modo
da diffondere e cosciente e consapevole
per l'esistenza del vento questa questo
controllo nella scienza il fatto che
lascia entrare in qualche modo sia
asservita al controllo dell'angolo enna
in qualche modo non estremizzazione di
questa di questo modo di pensare
materialista e ci ha portato ad una
società consumista che questo può
escludere l'altra desidero creare
barriere faber e sfrutta il lavoro e la
vita di altre persone che non hanno sono
talmente avanzate come noi oppure che
non sono tutelate e protette con le
stesse tutele sociali ei miei affetti in
assenza ha già prodotto
se ci pensiamo un l'inizio del novecento
secolo scorso al prodotto i semi per
cambiare questa visione è stato in
questo momento sto pensando in
particolare per esempio la teoria della
relatività alle teorie della relatività
ristretta e quella generale una foto in
cui i concetti assoluti e indipendenti
lo spazio ma soprattutto il tempo che
credevamo fossero indipendenti astuti
realtà sono relativi a aiutare dove gara
tra di loro e più si parla di spazio
tempo e in più sono relativi al sistema
di osservazione assist e conservate alle
velocità delle stime di ristorazione di
quello osservato in qualche modo è tutto
collegato il tutto connesso
qual è il mio scorso qui non è tanto di
espormi la teoria della relatività
quando piuttosto quella di farvi notare
una cosa una somiglianza è quella di
comici quali varia dalla stessa verità
attraverso strade differenti quello che
ho appena detto sulla teoria della
relatività esposto perdere in questa
frase che potrebbe essere
questa frase detta da chi sta
indirettamente 30 questa frase detta da
squali il canada e mistico in cui sta
che vi soggiornano nello stesso periodo
di vista l'ampiezza del 1900 e quindi il
mio sforzo con questo esempio che l'ho
fatto eco il prossimo presto per farvi è
quello di vedere come effettivamente
possiamo percepire la realtà con la
parte razionale comprendere il sezionale
le cose categorizzata le frasi da me lo
possiamo intuirlo e viverla in qualche
modo in altri il esempio successivo è
quello classico della meccanica
quantistica discussione di questa
l'esempio classico della meccanica
quantistica in cui sappiamo questo
canone di particelle carne di elettroni
che spara contro uno schermo che sta al
di là di questa lastra competenti tour e
spara dentro questo esperimento racco
per comprendere se le elezioni avessero
una natura di particella di onde perché
superando questa la strada dove finì 2 a
esposta è stata una particella alternerà
basso e strisce verticali
rappresentative dell'elettronica proprio
allo schermo se non sei stata un'onda in
questo del minuto
questo nella figura che con un partner
ne di interferenza perché superandolo
quest'ostacolo come non si sarebbe auto
generato interferenza
questo pattern di interferenza tra la
cosa che si scoprì nella magia in
qualche modo della meccanica quantistica
e che si comporta da un alle momenti in
cui per esempio mettiamo un osservatore
c'è un dispositivo prima della lastra
per capire in quale delle due finiture
per entrare sta per passare a diventare
invece una particella quindi assume uno
stato di quello che si dice che in
realtà del sole può assumere stato
avvicendato un'atomica professore
entrambe le componenti
questa è una particella questa è una ma
una è stato sulla funzione d'onda da
questo suo comportamento e con massa in
uno stato definito per quello di
particella in uno dei suoi particolari
ora oltre a questa magia della meccanica
quantistica ce ne sono altri giudico
magia perché escono state parzialmente
ma non completamente dimostrata e capite
è un'altra magia della meccanica
quantistica è quella che in qualche modo
far sognare i romantici è la generazione
di due particelle attraverso un
generatore di particelle e vengono
mandate i più distante possibile dalla
distanza che può essere anche definita
se operiamo su una delle due particelle
modificandone una proprietà per esempio
lo spino cela la rotazione della
particella questo questo cambiamento
vari fare immediatamente istantaneamente
la particella rientrata da una parte del
mondo magari questo in apparente
violazione
un posto caldo di einstein niente più
veloce della loro stella luce quindi lui
stesso definiva questa questo
comportando studi ex stradista nazionale
spalle in posa a distanza perché si
sente comprensibile però ci siamo anche
l'abito grazia quantistica che masada
punto su questo quindi lo utilizziamo
fine esiste per l'ultima magia voglio
parlarvi per tornare con il paragone fra
i modi diversi di comprendere le cose e
relativo alla berlin quantistico in
pratica una particella come delle
persone può superare una barriera d'auto
potenziale
nonostante questo dalla meccanica
classica sia si è completamente
impossibile è in realtà ritene
quantistico ad esempio sappiamo la
fusione nucleare che viene fra il coni
nel persone e che c e sali alla luce e
che riceviamo più di grazie grazie alla
meccanica quantistica samorì variati dal
dal sole sarà per continuare un paragone
sulle differenti su differenti modi di
comprendere tutto questo tutti questi
esempi che vi ho postato questi
esperimenti questa semplice la meccanica
quantistica mi fanno venire in mente che
materia la parola materia in realtà
viene dalla radice sanscrita ma e tutte
le lingue robert schumann utilizzano la
stessa parola ma dei spagnolo emergere
in un ex banchiere francese quindi più
facilmente alla stessa parole questa
radice sanscrita ma in realtà significa
creare creare e allo stesso tempo
mistral e quindi vedete le due facce
tramite la misurazione in qualche modo
stiamo creando qualcosa in quantità
super mario è anche nel nostro metodo ma
la cosa più importante fatto ieri ma è
anche dalla riserva parlava mai a
linguisti e finzione l'apparenza della
prima infilarsi divertente vedere come
le illusioni l'apparenza linguisti
diventi la materia fondamentale che
studiamo i laboratori di fisica in
occidente paranà per tirare le somme
cultura di tornare in un discorso finale
studiando dalla fisica moderna
quello che è quello che ho capito io
andrò a tre mesi nella teoria della
relatività di meccanica quantistica è
che non possiamo considerarci fuori dal
sistemi qualche modo siamo gli
osservatori siamo parte del sistema e
con la nostra stessa sola osservazione
stiamo già modificato la realtà che
vediamo e ricordando il cibo
di mostrarvi mesi fa c'è la materia dei
sogni di questa realtà
in realtà di parole è una danza acustica
di energia nella via che scrisse
costantemente che fa sì che cambi
costantemente riforma quindi cambi in
maniera permanente che realizzando forme
e materie che sono fermati invece anche
questa realtà e non ce la possiamo
comprendere non solo cercando di
controllarla la nostra razionalità ma
anche trovando tra il sognato tutto il
clan
intuendo la in qualche modo ad esempio
attraverso la meditazione peso alla
meditazione come strumento per creare
pensiero di alimenti vengono in mente le
misure rese quaranti di 40 giorni nel
deserto dal fare torno
avendo appreso di come separare il male
del medium fremaux mezzo che scrisse le
prime e più sicuri penso alle prime fasi
dei visti a milano dalle sue meditazioni
costanti regolari della collina di amici
che manca o di punta come tutti noi si è
illuminato grazie alla realizzazione e
quindi per concludere è concludere
quello che ci sono creativi e che
combatto interiormente
tra queste due queste due
quella di di chi vuole esplorare il
mondo è capito in maniera razionale e
quindi comprendo lo sforzo dei fisici
andare nella realtà esteriore ganasse
nella realtà esteriore cercare di
comprendere la verità l'ultima linguisti
e bramante ma allo stesso tempo seguito
questa necessità di andare dentro
scavare dentro cercare più potrà fanno i
mistici meditazione all'interno per
cercare la verità ultima che sta dentro
per gli induisti houtman ed è quello nel
momento in cui brahman
ma la verità all'esterno ed all'interno
del meeting percepisco che in realtà
sono la stessa verità l'unica verità che
la contemplazione controllo stramondo le
facce della stessa medaglia
incremento che sale a prima la
consapevolezza che effettivamente il mio
pensiero e coi miei sogni
sto costruendo la realtà in forme
conclude non so se sono riuscito in
questo alcuni serbi che siamo fatti
della stessa materia dei sogni ma volevo
concludere con delicato questo mio dolce
con le parole di cervantes a tutti i
parchi per amore missionari ai colleghi
del quotidiano e spinti ai hd che
darebbero la vita per un sogno
anche lì che non vogliono distinguersi e
la funzione a tutti i cavalli
[Applauso]